so i'm going to start with the most
important question which is um
how much are you both getting from
uh like from ireland from all the people
that are going to travel there after
seeing this movie
i mean i do you think we're gonna get a
cut from i i would hope that
air lingus could throw us a throw us a
cut of that but um
i mean i find it so sumptuous to look at
this film i it makes well i was there
but it makes you want to go back there i
mean it's just
it is like in this otherworldly jurassic
beautiful place and
to get to have worked there and
experience it and the people and the
spirit of the people
and how warm and brilliant they all are
i mean
come on who wouldn't want to go to
ireland after seeing this
oh i've been there and i wanted to go
back the second the movie ended
you know so you know um and the other
question i really wanted to know was
how much guinness do you think you guys
drank on an
offset i mean jamie drank
not not nearly enough um was that
guinness that we had in the kitchen
scene was that real or not i can't
remember
is that real or fake fakey no
i think towards the end of the day i i
asked for some um
some real some real uh state but it
wasn't guinness um
so uh you know you don't always don't
always get away in this
in this industry you know but we
definitely drank a lot of it
you know um it almost should exclusively
only be drank in ireland i i would
almost say that
um so you've got to make up for it when
you're there you've got it you've got to
fill your boots uh my uh another thing
is do you feel like you had
what there wasn't enough rain in this
movie
i i felt it i i feel it looks a bit dry
um
it was so rainy and we had no time to
shoot it was like four or five weeks we
had to shoot the film
that john patrick shanley the director
said you know we will be shooting
whether it is the sun is shining or it
is pissing with rain or it's doing both
simultaneously we have no time
you have one or two takes and we're
moving on so
we were just exposed to the elements in
kind of a wonderful
way and but then they bring in the rain
machines for the really epic rain and
that i
i found was violent quite a violent rain
machine from my memory
for each of you i know that i know that
there's there's a lot of scripts out
there and i know that you probably
offered different things
what was it seriously what was it about
this particular script
and project that said i really want to
do this because the script is unlike
almost anything i've seen recently
yes jamie go on youtube you know it's
nice emily and i are usually up for the
same part in things so it's actually
nice to be presented with something
where we could actually work together on
something which was cool um
you know steve i think you know you and
i have talked about
john patrick's channel i think you're a
bit of a fan of his you know he he he
he with his name comes a lot of intrigue
you know and you know
it's going to be a pretty um
often quite peculiar world that he's
created with
um you know very very interesting
characters involved so
you know it it stood out you know and it
was sort of pushed to the top of uh
you know a big pile for emily and a
little pile for me
of scripts and and you know i uh i i
just
i read it and instantly was um you know
very enchanted by it you know i really
truly haven't read anything like it
i mean i think well i feel very
similarly i think there is
he is such a singular writer um there
there is something off kilter and
bewitching about how he writes and
i think this was a very personal story
for him it's about his family in ireland
and
and um just he almost writes in verse
you know it's like
it's almost like the more rural and more
stunning the landscape gets the more
poetic the people become
and that's been his experience of
ireland and that's what he tried to
to bring out in these characters and um
it's just the writing i remember reading
it and going my god for the first time
it's like a romance where people are
strange and odd and awkward and cautious
and scared and it just felt terribly
human to me i loved it